hello Fandango movie clips with the pass
brothers directors of the biblical
apocalypse film Jerusalem forget you
primed and ready to check out Jerusalem
we're going to give our top 5 favorite
religious horror movies number 5 on our
list is 2009 s drag me to hell
an old woman curses Christine who must
figure out how to rid herself of the
demons that haunt her directed by Sam
Raimi the mastermind behind the Evil
Dead films written by Sam and his
brother Ivan the fourth film on our list
is wreck with a perfect blend of both
style and substance director Jean
Balaguer oh and Paco Plaza set out to
create a classic horror movie but to
tell the story more like a TV show
record falls in real-time and attempts
to immerse the viewer in the experience
through the eyes of a TV reporter and
her cameraman the production is sparse
with an almost custom phobic feel where
something horrifying and unknown is
happening number three is a devil's
advocate we're talking about director
guy Greene's 1977 West German
english-language film not the Keanu
Reeves Al Pacino film of the same name
the devil's advocate does the story of
Roman Catholic priest
the priest is sent to remote Italian
village to play devil's advocate in the
investigation of a man who is a
candidate to be canonized by the church
- we have Roman Polanski's classic
psychological horror film Rosemary's
Baby centering around rosemary Woodhouse
a young housewife who along with her
husband moves into a fancy pardal
building where strange things began to
happen when she wakes with scratch marks
all over her body and soon received news
that she is pregnant things take a
decidedly evil turn which brings us to
number one on our list
it's an exorcist William Friedkin's 1973
masterpiece that was the first whole
film to be nominated for the Best
Picture Academy Award the head-turning
vomit spewing demonically possessed well
the old girl this year
potty mouth is pretty much hollywood's
gold standard for evil personified and
there you have it our top five favorite
religious horror movies and that should
be perfect to get you ready to check out
our film jerusalem tells the story of
two young american women who travel to
tel aviv for a vacation but are
persuaded to change their plans by young
archaeologist and pretty soon all hell
breaks loose and they find themselves in
the middle of the biblical apocalypse
I'm your mom and this is my brother
drone for Fandango movie clips be sure
to check out Jerusalem in theaters
out
you